since before the you referendum there
have been fears that hiring would falter
as employers exercise caution ahead of a
period of uncertainty but a study by the
recruitment firm Reid has found that
after a brief slowdown in job
advertising in June it picked up in
October to above its pre referendum mark
the sector's that saw the biggest rise
in hiring in 2016 included purchasing
security and safety and health and
medicine with employers appeared
reluctant to invest in training
apprenticeships and graduate
traineeships all of which saw a
significant fall the part of a country
with the most new jobs on offer was
Northern Ireland which was up by more
than 50% the capital was at the lower
end of the scale rising by just 2.2
percent but the only part of the country
where job offers actually fell was the
southeast excluding London James Reid is
the company's chairman joins me now
James before we get onto that what did
you make of those Robert goodwill
comments I mean this levy will have
really got employees panicking won't it
yeah not much I mean it was another idea
that was floated and shot down on the
same day as you said and and I mean it
it didn't make much sense and hopefully
was seen the back of it yeah so very
couraging yes statistics from you today
this this survey what does Britain was
behind it yeah well it's very
interesting I mean since the beginning
of January that that was last year's
data that you just reported on since
being in January we've had 86,000 new
jobs on our website and that's 18
percent up on the same time last year so
that pace of accelerating employment
prospects is increasing can employers
actually fill these roles is there a bit
of a it's just tightness in the labour
market kind of push up wages because
most people expect inflation to overtake
wages this year yeah that's a danger and
so I think that the the fact that the
more more employers looking is
potentially good for wages wages have
been stuck for a long time I mean it's
in everyone's interest that wages go up
so I'm hopeful that wages will go up
this year if this trend continues why
this reluctance on the part of employers
to invest in training and
apprenticeships do you think I think
there was a lot of uncertainty in the
summer and people just took a moment to
think about what they wanted to do and
an apprenticeship is a long-term
commitment
whereas hiring someone straight away
maybe doesn't feel quite the same so I
think that's happened I hope that that
will change with apprenticeships coming
in now on a bigger scale with the
apprenticeship levy so I'm hoping that
will change I mean almost approaching
the point now where where you can talk
about full employment do you think we
get there yet I mean is there a danger
that this is as good as it gets for the
job market we're at record levels of
employment which is really good I mean
it's continuing to improve but then we
hear about you know machine learning new
technologies jobs disappearing but the
more I hear about driverless cars the
more driving jobs come on our website so
if something strange is going on that's
a very interesting point that you make
about I mean this technological age
really catching up and Watson what
advice to older workers right now who
might feel they're in danger of being
left behind by all this do your best to
keep up I mean in fact the new
technology is easier to use than the old
stuff so keep up to date I find that
never dream of hearing that James look
at what your kids are using yeah yeah
absolutely
now what about this downturn though in
the southeast is that a brexit effect or
is it just other factors I think the
southeast is a pretty saturated labor
market already you know there's a huge
concentration of employment in the
southeast I think a lot of employers are
probably looking to expand their
businesses in other parts of the UK and
that's why those are those are growing
faster and in terms of where we are for
the rest of the year where do you see
job creation being at its strongest
well I'm very positive about the year
ahead I mean we heard about sterling
falling but that's good for a lot of
businesses in the UK the last time that
happened in 92 in a big way we had a 15
year run so I'm very positive about this
year and I think it'll be jobs across
the sector and across the country but
particularly in technology and
manufacturing well given the government
wants to talk about having an industrial
strategy you think manufacturing has a
renaissance this year then yeah I do I
think that's a real prospect